[Music]
the site director was boiling over with
rage this was supposed to be a safe
facility one where low threat and
well-behaved humanoid scps were kept
with minimal security but if this kept
up these containment breaches could
easily bring the attention of scp brass
the last thing any of them wanted can
anyone explain the director demanded
pausing to calm himself why do we have
so much trouble keeping this subject
safely contained this is not the first
containment breach the security team
looked at each other nervously well sir
nothing is ever certain we made sure
everyone has the proper security
protocols in place but scps are always
unpredictable it's a little girl the
director slammed his fist on the table
look at these security protocols stuffed
animals play time this girl is obviously
not a threat so what's going on here the
security heads exchanged another nervous
glance ah you're right sir the specimen
isn't the security threat here it's the
researchers
scp-2118 was secured by the foundation
with both minimal apprehension as well
as a smaller team of personnel after
multiple reports of her unique abilities
were identified she appears to be a
normal child under 10 years of age with
orange hair and a long scar on her right
cheek 2118 claims that her scar is the
result of an assault by a stranger on
the street she communicated this via
sign language as she rarely if ever
vocalizes words she is however capable
of speech and that is where her unique
abilities lie
scp-2118 does not speak in her own voice
and it is still unclear as to whether or
not she even possesses one her speech
only activates in one situation in the
presence of a parent who has lost a
child under the age of 18 to death under
this circumstance only will scp-2118
begin to speak but rarely in the same
voice twice because
scp-2118's voice isn't her own
automatically and involuntarily 2118's
voice pattern becomes that of the child
who died speaking to their parent in a
way that reflects both the age and
gender of their deceased offspring the
voice that is heard is referred to as
scp-2118-01 by the foundation scp-218
is aware of her speech and vocal
patterns as well as the psychological
distress they caused the parent as she
will use sign language to apologize even
as
[Music]
scp-2118-01 continues speaking but this
isn't the only disturbing part of her
abilities while at first the
conversation can be generic most times
the words and sounds coming out of
scp-2118's mouth reflects the final
words and sounds of the dead child this
not only includes disturbing pleas for
help but can reflect the actual sounds
of dying mimicking the agony of drowning
disease or death by fire
scp-2118 wasn't necessarily a danger to
anyone however her presence could
absolutely pose a dangerous temptation
the director finished looking over the
files it seemed like everything had been
handled smoothly and by the books when
scp-2118 was initially brought in but
along the way something had gone wrong
the case was being handled by one of his
most trusted researchers dr wu as it
became clear that scp-2118 didn't talk
normally translators who could interpret
asl were brought in for the first
interview dr wu and site psychologist dr
lavoy welcomed this strange little girl
to the scp facility this interview
provided the foundation its first intel
on where
scp-2118 had come from at first the
little girl was alarmed she didn't like
being referred to by her scp number and
insisted on her original name she
understood that she was in a science lab
of some sort but thought she had been
brought there because she had done
something wrong she referenced a woman
attacking her with her purse at one
point and also claimed that any time she
spoke people would get angry but then
she revealed something more disturbing
she knew why people got angry when she
spoke from her mother she had lived with
her parent and at some point her mother
had lost a baby after the traumatic
incident every time 2118 spoke she spoke
in the voice of the sibling she had lost
this caused her mother to become angry
and out of shame provoked 2118 to glue
her own mouth shut to prevent it from
happening due to the glue being a little
too strong it resulted in a visit to the
hospital something she thought might
happen again at the facility but no one
was sure if she was scared of it or
hoping for it more than anything the
little girl just didn't want people to
stop talking to her the foundation had a
long way to go in understanding
scp-2118's abilities dr lavoy and dr wu
both seemed to have a good rapport with
the girl and they were kept in charge of
her case neither one had children and
could converse with her without
difficulty as long as a translator was
present but to test her abilities there
would have to be an experiment conducted
involving someone who could actually
activate them and it just so happened
that dee 3498
a volatile conscript working at the
facility had been convicted of the
murder of his wife and his daughter but
the experiment would prove to be more
than anyone was bargaining for as soon
as d3498 was brought in
scp-2118 became silent after about 30
seconds she signed an apology for what
was about to happen and then began
screaming at the top of her lungs she
cried out for her father in an anguished
voice all while signing apologies d3498
became increasingly angry demanding to
know what was going on he struggled
against his restraints and howled
obscenities as he listened to his
daughter's strangled pleas for help
begging and ultimately her death rattle
two agents recorded as agent m and agent
c were brought in to end the experiment
and remove d3498
and that's when things took an
unexpected turn while agency removed the
d-class h m seemed oddly fixated on
scp-2118
the reason why became clear as soon as
scp-2118
opened her mouth mama the voice had
changed completely to that of a young
boy several years older than the
d-class's daughter the boy seemed
distraught complaining of being cold and
scared and wanting to know where his
mother was agent m seemed frozen in
place and didn't answer dr lavoy's
questions the experiment was quickly
terminated
scp-2118 was removed to her living
quarters and agent m was removed from
duty with the case of a possible missing
or murdered child referred to police
authorities
scp-2118 may have cracked a cold case
but she also posed a dangerous
temptation it wouldn't be long before
the case had its first security breach
researcher anselmon conducted an
interview with scp-2118
despite not being assigned to the case
anselmon didn't have access to the scp's
living quarters so he watched
scp-2118 sleep and then communicated
with her through the glass the events
were captured on facility cameras and
showed that scp-2118 was agitated from
the start knowing that anselmon was not
supposed to be there and anselmann had
an ulterior motive as soon as the
conversation began
scp-2118 using sign language asked
anselmon why she was being made to do
this soon afterwards
scp-2118 started speaking in the voice
of a prepubescent boy that anselmon
called dewey and who referred to
anselmon as dad the boy was clearly
agitated as was
scp-2118 and asked his father what
happens after they die anselman became
upset wanting to hear answers from his
lost son not questions
scp-2118 tried to warn him off letting
anselmann know that he couldn't actually
communicate with his son through her and
she couldn't help him but anselmann
persisted watching as
scp-2118 imitated the sound of a boy
gasping and taking his last breaths
consistent with a death from illness
rather than accident or violence all the
while
scp-2118 just watched sadly the security
breach was soon discovered and
researcher anselmon was removed and
reprimanded for unauthorized testing
with scp-2118
but thanks to the researchers breach the
foundation did gain new knowledge of
scp-2118's abilities namely that she
couldn't actually channel the spirits of
the dead she was a mimic who could
involuntarily duplicate their last
moments but couldn't provide any new
information from them or answer
questions that they didn't know in life
and she didn't have any special
knowledge of what came after life
but her abilities did have one unique
potential by channeling the last moments
of a deceased child she could possibly
provide answers for authorities as to
their whereabouts or their killer as she
had unexpectedly done with agent m the
problem was this process seemed to be
deeply disturbing for scp-2118
who showed great emotional distress when
forced to channel a dead child and
consistently apologized for the effect
on the parents which left the foundation
in an ethical dilemma
sir how do you want to proceed the site
director looked over the files clearly
this couldn't continue and something
needed to be done but none of the
security breaches or other incidents had
been
scp-2118's fault she had been
cooperative despite the trauma these
tests seemed to cause her to keep her
safe and to preserve her use to the
foundation things would need to change
we could transfer scp-2118 to a more
secure facility but i'm not going to do
that keep herself furnished with all the
things a girl her age would want it says
here that she likes orcas and elephants
take her outside to an enclosed play
area once a day for about an hour no
more but above all make sure she's
always with an attendant who can
converse in sign language she's not to
be around anyone who has had children
unless it's necessary for testing convey
these new parameters to doctors wu and
lavoy and make sure to increase security
around her quarters as much for her
protection as anything else the security
team scurried off happy to have avoided
the director's wrath the director turned
back to the files yes he had solved the
problem for now but he would have to
keep a closer eye on the facility as a
whole the scp foundation did close
background checks on its staff and on
d-class personnel before bringing them
in but scps were unpredictable and you
never knew what could make someone a
security risk how many employees working
at the facility had lost a child how
many like the disgraced researcher
anselmon would do anything to hear their
child's voice again even if it was in
the middle of death for another story of
a seemingly harmless child with unusual
effects check out
scp-053 young girl or watch this video
instead